hello Iran it's a cow assistant
professor in department of molecular and
human genetics at Baylor College for
Madison
yeah this is my great honor so share our
discovery and stories with you guys and
I did my postdoc year stem cell center
and Nichelle's lab that's where we make
this discovery you find a totally novel
DNA methylation in human and mouse and
before then I get my PhD in Chinese
general science actually in the in the
genomics and the paramedics background
okay so now I will start to present my
story Peter you can see the title that
tell you we find a noble game a
collation six mess of adenine in mouse
and human okay we are at the genetics
lab so instead I'll show you
very old-style Weddington diagram I like
this pinball diagram better because in
this picture it's exactly tell you the
cool ideas or concept in the epigenetic
field is the dynamics the emts histone
acetylase or the you see delays or some
unknown component here all these
epigenetic machine work together and
finally make a decision and make the
self-weight decision and goes through
the different developers or
reprogramming paths and finally the step
in one state and I feel why I joined
this field and try to do the epigenetics
research because in this field it's tons
of the unknown or anti scoured component
and exciting field is left so you can
make
your contribution in the future - okay
here what i show you as SIL today what's
known DNA modification or so-called
functional DNA modifications in
mammalian genome you can see here from
beginning we have the cycles in that's
the normal base in our body and the fly
methyl settled in is the first one
characterized in a million genome the
modification on the cytosine that's a
methylation on the carbon and this was
known for about over 40 years and in
2009 dr. engineer Yahoo just discovered
five hi girl my so cited in here data
oxidation and methylation product from
the fly mesocycle team led wrong John
and try to and jung-soo several groups
together with them and also column she's
lab then they discovered five home
muesli and five cabaco see and finally
they discovered enzyme called cat cat
one attitude has three they can be
massive place the five my selected in
step by step one by one finally back to
the sight of them so it's a circle and
finished this modification d
modification circle and this already
been done in the last ten years and the
pathway enzyme is very clear however
there is another question left in the
field also for about forty years
even from beginning define define my so
titled in someone asked
we have the Masel Adnan in mammalian
system unfortunately several groups try
to searching for this for about 20 years
but before 2015 this and six mass of
Aden is only reported in the e.coli and
no one discovered this even in
eukaryotes and in 2015
three papers published on self gather
from trial youngsil and the Hodgins
group report is new adenine methylation
in cruelty to saw Flair and style
elegance that's the first time we found
this methylation in the UK rose and then
one year later we discovered is and
Sigma adenine a mouse embryonic stem
cells that's we this job in yield stem
cell center ah that's I'm the first
author and I did this job in a new cells
lab so okay this slice seems very simple
but takes the whole field for about 40
years and now the field is still moving
on and definitely for me is no doubt
will we will find more and more
undiscovered unknown normal
modifications in our body and hope you
guys can join very soon and okay and I
will tell you how we cover this no more
modifications I did my postdoc Angus
laughs our first
scientific parallel question is try to
figure out one type of the system is to
a variant h2 a dot X this warrant is
only contributed about five to ten
percent of the total whole nuclear zone
in the mouse embryonic stem cells so
that means they deficit to the genome
maybe it by random or they can target
specific low side so in my first
published paper yield that one in that
one we discovered okay the atria dot X
deposition pattern is really important
for the Yamanaka flow factor IPS l
induced pluripotent stem cells to gain
the fully prepotency that means this
warrant deposition is not random and
they have there is the Pacifica low side
they should carve it and this target
deposition happen and important for the
selfish decision and just follow that
walk we ask okay then what's the signal
or medicine on the genome will serve as
the recruiting signal to recruit the
Patriot Act's to the specific or right
low saionji so well the hypothesis it's
very simple for for the issue acts
deposition either maybe you have some
specific motif or sequence or you have
some maybe specific modifications like
family so sensitive and then hang we
know from metal center to unify our
message without hypocrisy carboxy so
either way maybe they cancer
recruiting signal to recruit is radon
tax deputies specific law that right
so the hypothesis one word is special
streams here for the special beats so to
test this hypothesis the classical way
is to do the hte dot ax chip C and if
you doubt the finest of citizen or 5
hacker - antigen is a signal then you do
the maybe whole genome bisulfite
sequencing then to correlate to these
two and do the analyze to see the
correlated stop each other or not but
instead of to do that I try to do some
killer impairment to answer this
question directly so that's why I use
the Pacific bioscience the smart
sequencing so-called single molecule
real-time sequencing technology coupled
with the histone native chip here the
slide just show you my experimental
design from beginning we just do the
native cheap to cool down the h2 a dot X
nucleosomes bonding DNA fragment with
the a trade of hacks antibody and
different to the classical so-called
Illumina secondary sequencing you need
to do the PCR amplify or pulldown
sequence set up a library here for the
backpal smarty we do not do the PCR just
add the circularized
sequencing adapter to cool down the
native DNA fragments and then load this
on the smart sequence while and put them
on the sequence machine to start
sequence here I just explain a little
bit of this sequencing technology you
can see here is so-called
Samarra sequencing the while and
decoys so-called zero more I don't know
what that and then you hold your
sequence fragment that you want to
sequence in the while and the propeller
ages the causing here they have a
modified DNA polymerase and when the
additive polymerase they bound to the
sequencing adapters then they can start
to read your fragment sequence tell you
it's the ICTR key the base information
remember at at the same time we didn't
do the PCR if you have any modification
on these fragments when the enzyme goes
through the modification its well-known
depends on will take longer time to go
through the modified a compared to the
unmodified a so finally this sequencer
give you two dimension information one
is the phase information TCG or a
another one is so-called kinetics or the
next of the enzyme goes through each
base so to calculate this support in the
products division time of the enzyme
collude read the space you will know the
pace is modified or unmodified so it's
something like you drive a car from A to
B and then if it goes through correctly
or flat will be quick
but if you faced some you know the he'll
they will take a longer time to pass it
so okay then with these power single
molecule sequencer after our first round
of sequencing the shockingly low come
out with help from the people about in
15 they told us sorry
we didn't see anything five kabak cr5
messy or fractional Mississippi instead
we see tongues of modified a there so
Adam hi
no I know we have the six metal a denier
or other modified and in in mouse or
human genome so from beginning without
off it's something contamination but
took me about three or four months with
different analysis protocol and I figure
out oh no this is something real it's
not some fourth quality of our
contamination there at the same time as
I told you a beginning the three cell
paper just published and then suddenly
we know all in at least you Carol's we
have this modified a methylation so and
then we just sex for the the other three
groups and we know exactly and you know
that standard methodology in the field
so we just used a different approach the
you PLC mass spectrometry and also
muscle DNA IP sequencing and different
methodologies to cross confirm and to to
make sure our discovery is real party so
here you can see we get the standardized
that you know the muscle eight-six
muscle is a iced over label and then we
use this as a standard reference and
characterize what we discovered in the
embodied stem cell so you can see
with our economic be a it sees the
internal standard there any sickness of
a so this just tell you what we see on
the sequencer it is the metal atom II is
not the other modifications like one
metal area or something else
and from this quantification you can see
the h2 a dot X pull down IP samples it
has really enriched this methylation
compared to the genomic background so
here I just to show you instead of just
discover a normal methylation we also
characterize the first the methylase of
this intensive metal adenine in Mouse
and what extends out that so-called al
kph watching this change in called this
one protein and if you knock out this
email is you can see in the knockout
cells compared to one half cells this
methyl and any level goes up and here is
the most by geometry quantification
result you can see after you knock out
every one either the genomic whole
genome are the e3 at food apart all all
has the more sickness or any methylation
compared to the wild evolution
so it just means a orchid one in called
the methylase for this methylation
yeah from another angle just tell you
okay this methylation is not something
like a duck or no useful they just tell
you they can be dynamic regulate add-on
or delete yeah by the specific enzymes
here just show you the whole impairment
of the individual becomes athlete
two-car garage
the elk x1 as the demethylase of the
metal atom in you justice inside the
incidental a illegals and then add the
recombinant protein plus the cofactors
together and then you can see the pivot
one can be methylated this methylation
and if you add one less adding in
another mess of a the electron cannot be
matelassé this modification so here is
the respect atomic recodification for
the methylation incision so in vitro and
in vivo both we demonstrate air
compressor and the methylase for this
noble methylation so after then we just
ask okay so what's the function of this
noble methylation like families of sleep
they can suppress gene expression so how
about this new methylation so we did the
artistic compared lqr knockout and the
world height Manik stem cells remember
of is why is a demophalus so after you
knock out they are applied means gain
function after in signatory so with our
in sticker you can see it's very clear
the signal I serve as a suppressor
instead of activator the function
reported in the other of needed like in
plot R or the table so it's very
interesting
later on we need to figure out okay why
in the plant or the table serve as
activator but in mouse or human history
the suppressor instead of the genes here
when I show you as I also analyze the
so-called Drunken admin or you called
John Kerry means near our genome is the
transposons especially Regional
Transport ons
here you can see it's very clear for us
and sickness
a also not only suppressed G is also for
the ritual transpose especially this
lion one family and the younger age
LimeWire subfamily elements and the lion
one contribute about 20% to mouse or
human genome so it's a super family of
the researcher hold on
and the so-called young aged some family
of this virtual photo it just means they
are still they have the ability to jump
in or Kino so it's very interesting to
find this normal methylation specific
target these so-called active rituals
has all the elements in the products
stem cells so these slides I just will
show you is one case with our DNA methyl
EAA IP sequencing impairment just to
tell you okay we're the special a locate
in the mouse embryonic stem cells you
know and compared well as you can see
knockout we have mini killing increased
signal and here you can see this schema
so a peak just sit down and one younger
line was double families of called Arawa
mbae subfamily adamantly and just note
we have another very important
development Oh functional elements
that's what the gene that's why it's in
called very important development Oh
possibly
Cheers and so you can see these two is
flanking to each other so with several
case like this trigger me too
[Music]
to propose a hypothesis model so in
summary you can see what I show you we
discover an oval additive methylation
and sickness or a in the mouse and
buttock stem cell and it's emasculates
every one and we also find this one can
target either genes are mainly on the
ritual tranpose of animals and they can
suppress the transcription here and
after you knock out everyone
the demethylation smelly level goes up
and we impart target to the young age
family of the language elements then
they can suppress their transcription
maybe Junction John McJunkin too and
also you have terms of the development
of functional genes flanking to this
line elements so the line elements to us
is just a serve as some you know the
anchor element here then we have also
says maybe snot over here
and we organized the chromatin contacts
like maybe form intro chroma key
flanking this element then of course the
flanking genes transcription shutter so
that's the working model in order 2006
nature paper so okay after that we just
asked a nice question so it seems in the
normal tissue or body
somatic cells no sickness of a there so
we have some hints to to say okay maybe
in the outer early and broad development
this modification may be surrounded
prodded function there
yeah we don't have enough material
figure out that question or hypothesis
yet instead of that we just predict okay
instead of the normal tissue or
ourselves maybe in the unknowable ones
like the cancers could we fundraise
modifications or not because remember
the epigenetics the landscape is just
like a few the normal development the
cells just go through and it takes
several so-called noble normal somatic
cells state you can see the Pacer here
just to show you the normal state
I remember we also have some where
unnormal cell state so that maybe show
us if the cancer cells or something
we ourselves else and so in this stage
you didn't the function mess away but
it's not me as in those weird state you
cannot find them
so we collaborate with dr. Jeremy rich
lab which in UCSD now Jeremy is the
pioneer scientist who just defined
glioblastoma stem cells and so we
collaborate with Jeremy's lab and take
advantage of their clear and and and
well-defined they can of glial blastoma
stem cell system and to characterize the
sickness of a function there so from
beginning we get a very shocking you
thought and it's promising because you
can see here with the table in the
glioblastoma stem cell lines and even in
the primary glioblastoma cecil's
compared to the our normal control kin
the exercise the signal
we'll reach are very much higher
abundance and this is the mass
spectrometry qualification you can see I
didn't mark the mouse and what extends
ll here I can tell you the 1000 ppm here
is around about three hundred five
hundred fold higher than the signatory
level in the mouse buttock stem cells so
it is ultra high so it justit rigorous
okay to see where are they
and what's the function so here I got to
show you this is the immuno
immunostaining with the antibody see
they are indeed in the nucleus this is
after are is a are STRs is treatment so
very low or no are a multiplication
background and you can see it's overlap
with within the nucleus perfect and here
is I to see figure you can see in the
colliculus Tomo this mastery level is
much higher than normal brain tissues
here it's the quantification of this
figure so it's in the real TCO is
significant higher than the normal brain
tissue of the sickness or acne so then
we did the whole genome muscle six a IP
sequencing and then you can see sickness
or adenine is bias the heavily you reach
overlap with the future chromatin part
which we mark here is the h3k9
trimethylation intricate domain or h3k27
trimethylation domain here and in the
heat map you can see it's very clear
semester a and clean i and 7 is
co-localize together so that's just
indicate it seems Cygnus
Allanon in the colliculus Toma maybe
serve together with heterochromatin
components or induct to to to to hold
our our form the specific chromatin
compacts in this tumor cells so we also
check the lqr human fifth one and we
confirm it also serves as the signature
item athletes you can see we knock down
the apples one this message increase and
also you give the RFC you can see after
at which one knock down signatory level
comes up in the global stoma and you can
see more down regulate genes it just to
tell you okay
it serve as suppressor in the
glioblastoma and here you can see after
you know kalam team athlean sigma say
increased then you can see much more
it's written i trimethylation the codes
gained people are increased domain
compared the decrease in last on it so
it just mean some house mercer a help
our are to to to collaborate with is
retain Nitra methylation in time to
perform more heterochromatin domains in
the Palio blastoma cells and this twice
just show you okay after enough out of
this one then you see towns of the
increase six muscle adenine peaks also
co-localize with the heterochromatin
body the extra Kenai trimethylation
domain and the comparative the thermic
background is heavily bias or enriched
in the edge to the Kenai trimethylation
I'll hit you committed
and here got to show you some how we can
use the chromatin increase or
information to explain our downregulated
genes you can see about our 80% of the
down reality is targeted by sickness or
a it's overlap with extra Kenai
trimethylation
get your chromatin down so it just means
after you knock our victim at least
Sigma so a increase and help to form or
mortgage grunting then Adam regulate
those important genes correlate to the
newer development our another very
important function I will show you in a
minute
so then with Germany's help
we just inject the lkb1 knock ourselves
into the mouse brain to task the tumor
formation compared to the world have
control you can see is it's some result
from beginning the imagine it's its
opposite so if you link Sigma so a
higher Sigma so a link to high-grade
glioblastoma you will imagine okay the
after you knock out that a methyl is
methyl a increase should shoot a mile
mice even sooner than the wildhack right
but here what i show you is after you
knock out the methylase then you inject
a knockout cells into the mouse brain
they show you okay they rescued that
Mouse and the signals of a songs in pyro
compromised the glioblastoma stem cell
tumor formation ability then we ask why
so I analyzed our kids won control genes
with the Jeana oncology you can see here
the memory clear the okay
one control pounds of the hydroxyl
response genes in the glioblastoma cells
so it just tell you okay maybe we need
to test the average one part the size
and these genes what the Sigma T looks
like and we also challenge stressed
global as tumor cells with a hypoxic
condition one percent oxygen compared to
twenty percent so I show you one kid
here it's very clear to tell you why
this is one knockout compromised the
glioblastoma stem cells tumor formation
vanity you can see x IA p is one
important hypothesis positives so when
you challenge or stressed GBM cells stem
cells the oxide AP should be up regulate
I mean increase in interest to response
this dress so here in the pneumonia you
can see cygnus of a peak here this is a
something like the silencer or
suppressor so they can suppress the
genes when you culture in hypoxic
conditions
give yourself stress then if it's warm
ourselves now each one can have two here
two demethylate this and sigma so a and
activate these genes response to the
hypothesis press or remember now in
knockout cells so you don't have this
demethylase so when you challenge are
you inject the cells into the poor in it
is always it's a hypoxia a niche or
contacts in the brain so the tumor need
to activate this gene but they don't
have this demethylase here and
demethylate incidentally so the cells
cannot response the hypoxia condition or
niche normally so give you time so
that's why we you knock out this
demethylase the cells instead of to
increase our health the tumor formation
confirm knockout cell yeah they can they
cannot form the tumor like the world
hyperbolas Tomas themselves okay that's
the whole story of the in segments of a
in glioblastoma stem cells now we are
just moving on try to test ok this mess
of a function in the other two models
and we also have some other work is
going on just to try to figure out the
important function of this new
methylation in the most early
development stage so here I gotta show
you a slice eyesight from schanke's
review just published last month just
all the non Sigma so in knowledge we
show here but I mean some of them may be
true some of them enough because the
field is just a star and keep moving on
so we need some time to figure out okay
what's the real enzyme and we have more
demethylase or users and also do we have
the readers or not so yeah you should
have you if you become uterus about the
field that you can go through and to
read this very good review paper and
finally I just aside schanke's centers
try to summary the status of the field
yeah we have more and more evidence for
signals of a in the mammalian genome but
we still need further studies to clarify
the ambiguities or some part like the
writer the methyl transferase is too
elusive now and we very important we
need to evolve more and more and
improved masters and approach to detect
and mapping this new modification so
we can get more and more clear to see
was a real function yeah of this normal
methylation so data exactly yeah I said
on my lab in biblical medicine and we
are developing mobile masters and we
also searching the collaborate to set up
a different new model system try to
characterize the function and new
pathways with this new methylation in
human disease such as cancer okay that's
all
finally thanks to my PhD postdoc advisor
dr. Michelle heal and my colleagues and
also our collaborators in PayPal and
Jeremy UCSD without their help we cannot
get this discovery and thanks to my
funding source especially the secret
secret is fantastic without secret money
I cannot set up my own lab in Baylor so
okay that's all yeah then I'll be glad
also any questions you have
thank you